Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
Continuing in real the chapter of
patience authored by Noahi. The first
narration in this chapter, the 25th
narration of the book, a narration on
the authority of Malik Ashi.
This narration is a collection of
sentences, statements that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam made.
These statements, each one of these
sentences is considered
a principle,
a foundation, a fundamental
upon which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
religion is built and based upon.
Each one of these statements that he
makes in this narration is considered to
be a principle and a fundamental
in every single subject that he touches
upon.
So he mentions in the first sentence
that purification is half of faith, half
of belief, half of iman. We spoke about
that briefly.
The second statement alhamdulillah
and alhamdulillah
fills the scales.
The third statement was subhan allahul.
The next statement,
subhan Allah and alhamdulillah.
These two fill or this statement
together fills and occupies all that is
between the heavens and the earth. What
does that mean? It occupies it fills all
that is between the heavens and the
earth. When we look at these two
statements together,
they together
make up
the
one of the most profound praises of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And these two
statements together
is what we base our belief in the names
and attributes of Allah upon.
our belief in Allah
in what we conceptualize
what we understand
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to be
described as to be named what he has
named himself what he has described
himself to us
that is based on subhan Allah
alhamdulillah
because subhan allah
means negating ing
anything that is imperfect for Allah.
When a person says subhan Allah,
they are essentially saying and they are
literally saying,
"Oh Allah, I proclaim that you
are free of any imperfection."
Number two, when we say alhamdulillah,
we are saying, "Oh Allah, I proclaim and
testify and believe that every
perfection belongs to you."
Every perfection belongs to you.
So we are uniting the two. We are
negating every imperfection
and we are then affirming every
perfection for Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
This is why
subhan Allah
it comes often in the Quran as a
rebuttal
to anything that is unbefitting of
Allah. For instance,
Subhan Allah.
A nephew.
Subhan.
Subhan Allah.
for
[Silence]
subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
So for instance, Allah says throughout
the Quran and they claim that Allah has
a child,
a child. Some say daughters, some
different religions, they claim that
Allah has begotten a son, begotten
offspring.
Subhanahu
subhanahu here means what? This is an
imperfection
and Allah is free of any imperfection.
Now notice when we say perfection and
imperfection it is respective
meaning what is a perfection for Allah
may be an imperfection for a creation.
What is perfection for the creation
could as well be an imperfection for the
creator.
So for instance
for Allah
it is an imperfection
to have an offspring to have a child for
the creation. This is part of the
perfection of the creation.
A perfection
for the human being is sleep. If a
person doesn't sleep, this person is
imperfect. This person is sick. This is
an illness.
However, with for Allah, sleep is an
imperfection. It is unbefitting of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
A perfection for Allah
is highness
and greatness.
This is an imperfection for the human
being. the human being. Humility is
perfection for the human being and great
arrogance is an imperfection for the
human being. Right? When it is
unrightful, we call it arrogance.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala knowing
everything
all that was and is and would be and all
that would have been had things been is
perfection for him. It is imperfection
for the human being.
For the human being, forgetting
or becoming confused, this is part of
being human. The human being is
perfectly imperfect
for Allah.
This is an imperfection.
There are things which are perfection
for Allah
and a perfection for the human being as
well patience but as well it is
relative. A human being's patience is
not comparable to Allah's patience.
However, patience is a universal
perfection.
And so
when we have these two together, when
the when the Muslim says subhan Allah
or the Muslim says subhan Allah
alhamdulillah,
they are essentially
affirming
perfect fundamentals
in their belief of Allah and his names
and attribut. utes subhanahu wa'ta'ala
all of the names and attributes of Allah
all of his actions every creation that
exists is a testament to his perfection
and his freedom from imperfection.
So when the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam says alhamdulillah subhan allah
and alhamdulillah
occupy
all that is between the heavens and the
earth
what is between the heavens and the
earth the creation of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala you and I and the air and the
animals and the trees and the
environment and space and whatever
all of these things are the creation of
Allah They are perfectly balanced. They
are perfectly
poised.
Everything that exists of the creation
of Allah
screams
subhan Allah. Alhamdulillah.
Everything is a testament
to subhan Allah and alhamdulillah.
Anywhere you look
in the perceivable creation,
all that you see is that which proclaims
subhan Allah. Alhamdulillah.
Therefore, he says sallall.aii wasallam
and subhan Allah and alhamdulillah
fill and occupy all that is between the
heavens and the earth.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]